foreign
just like thrusting Rock jams
is that your music Joe
that was Ben's incredible incredible all
right cool so for those that don't know
this is where we have 10 questions that
John has not seen
and I will ask him the question and he
has one minute to give us a brief answer
and then we move on to the next one and
this is your favorite because they are
because you don't know and I could I
can't say my name in a minute so yeah
and so this is one of my favorite things
that we do which is why we do it more
often now all right let's dance all
right so just so this one is on all of
these questions are around holiday
anxiety that our listeners sent in when
we asked you know what are your issues
around holidays
um and these are the 10 that we picked
okay all right let's let's sing and
dance question number one do I have to
buy my friends gifts at Christmas I
can't afford it but I don't want to look
like a cheapskate
no
you will only feel anxious if you let me
say it this way you you're gonna feel
anxious either way you're only going to
poison your relationships if you do
something that you can't otherwise
afford that is going to put you in a
less safe position so here's the right
way you're feeling anxious about it I
don't I don't feel like a cheapskate
cool go directly through that storm let
your friends know hey guys this is a
tough year financially for me so I'm not
doing gifts this year I'm gonna do
whatever I'm gonna write you all a song
I am going to sing your favorite song
and record it and y'all we're all going
to watch it whatever cheesy I don't care
whatever's coming up I'm gonna write you
a letter and let you know how much I
love you but this year I can't do gifts
and let it be choose guilt over
resentment choose the guilt of not
having a gift over the resentment of
buying stuff putting on a credit card
that you can't afford and it's gonna
cost you hell to pay weeks and months
down the road
look at that slit in there awesome all
right
how do you do holidays with your family
and in-laws when everyone lives in the
same city how do I live Without You nope
Time started already here's what you do
direct clear wonderful boundaries very
strict hey on Christmas morning we're
going to do uh until two o'clock just
our family just us no one else is going
to come over we're not going to go
anywhere we're just going to have our
own little time together we're gonna
have breakfast we're gonna get up we're
going to open presents on our own and
then we will go about whatever
um what nights are we going to get
together be very specific put it on a
calendar and hold everybody to it let
everybody know hey don't just we're not
just gonna have showing up at our house
we're gonna make sure the kids are still
going through their sleep routine we're
still going to have bad times we're not
going to just poison our kids with all
the sugar we're gonna leave that to a
couple of days boundaries boundaries
boundaries and I have found in my
personal life and with those I work with
Clarity on the front end saves Decades
of Heartache on the back end
awesome all right
how do I have conversations with my
family at the holidays when we are
politically divided don't don't say this
this magic phrase we are not talking
about politics and if anyone starts
talking about politics I will say I
don't want to talk about politics and if
they continue
you are asking me to leave and I will be
happy to oblige you
end of statement in my house we all have
different political beliefs some
radically different than others and it
makes for a fun Sport and it makes for
awful holiday time so every year we send
out a note uh email just a reminder no
politics and so we can all go back point
back to the email with somebody's like
well you know what's happening in hey
we're not doing that we already set the
boundaries no politics all right all
right all right and hey somebody turned
the news on no no no no no news why
would you do that why would you choose
to be like you know what I'm just gonna
take crap in the middle living room
don't do that no news no news
all right we are just flying through
these look at you
when I see my family at the holidays how
do I feel the intrusive questions like
when are you going to find a husband
[Laughter]
oh boy
directly right on the nose if somebody
has if somebody has the nerve to walk
out to me like so when are you gonna
find a husband
I would just say when a husband Finds Me
or when one shows up
or I don't know how's your marriage
going it doesn't look too great
like just slap it up flip it and reverse
it uh but those inch here's the deal
most people who ask those intrusive
questions are trying to show you that
they love you and just trying to invite
you into something maybe you didn't
maybe you didn't realize how great it is
being married and you thought just being
lonely and single was so wonderful they
might be trying to help so I'm gonna let
that roll off my back and if they keep
doing it say hey I'm not really
interested in talking about my dating
failures right now or I'm not interested
in talking about how much I love being
single right now uh let's talk about
other stuff
all right the next one is a two-parter
when is it acceptable to start listening
to Christmas music and then what is the
worst Christmas song ever
oh my gosh what a great question
I think it is
um morally and should be legally
um
what's the right word I think it's
immoral and it should be illegal let me
say it that way to listen to Christmas
music before
the Friday after Thanksgiving I know
some people who hate babies and uh hate
love and joy start on November 1 and
those people should be removed from
society they should be they should be
removed from society and no question the
worst Christmas song Jen is like dying
in there because she listens to
Christmas music year round I used to
have a buddy that I worked with named
Kevin Claypool he and Kevin I love it he
listened to Chris music all the time
although he loved it he loved it he
loved it he loved it man and I loved how
much he loved it I just think it's
immoral and
the worst Christmas Song Ever by far
Little Drummer Boy if somebody starts
playing a Little Drummer Boy
no no no that's all I'm gonna say about
that can I just say real quick here we
go it brings me joy so if I want
Christmas toy on November 1st dang it
I'm gonna have Christmas Joy November
1st I just think you should find joy and
other things that are more profitable
for Humanity that's all
that's all
Wendy what about you when do you start
listening to it
um not until after Thanksgiving because
you're a human yeah and you care about
America Joe when do you start
um well I guess around Thanksgiving I'm
old school
I appreciate that and you're wearing an
Alabama hat and I usually wouldn't take
your opinion seriously but I do now is
our opinions a line that's so humble all
right on to the next on to the next
how do we do Santa with our kids while
still teaching them that Jesus's birth
is the priority
I think that's just a false dichotomy
it's not an either or
um
Santa is a fun and I get this a lot like
you tell us say you don't lie to your
kids but let's tell them about Santa
light no it's participating in fun like
that that's like uh jumping out and
wearing a costume and scary like having
fun like Boo gotcha it's part of a
cultural story it's part of a cultural
myth that we're all a part of
um and some people consider the Jesus
story that too right if you full fully
believe in the Jesus story that has a
sense of reverence a sense of worship a
sense of awe and wonder the Santa it's
just fun it's just having fun and people
like my kid finds out they're gonna
think I'm a liar no they're not they're
gonna know that you participated in a
fun like man we were enjoying your
childhood as much as possible
um so I would hold they're not an either
or proposition like the birth of Jesus
in your home if that means the world to
you it's important in my house if it
means the world to you great have some
reverence around it and dude do
Christmas talk about Santa Claus do the
whole nine yards have fun with it
awesome
what is the best way to approach the
first holiday season after a loved one
has passed away
oh that's good
um I
really believe in getting Upstream as
much as possible with that one ask your
ask your family members how do we want
the best honor so and so during the
holidays
usually people don't have that
conversation and so there's a big gap
and everybody feels that Gap this
elephant just walks in the living room
and Parks right in the middle of the
living room and it's it just adds it's
like a a tractor beam for all the joy in
the room it just sucks it out of the
room so
send an email around to everybody hey
grandma died hey dad passed away this is
our first Christmas without dad I would
like all of us to
um write down on a piece of paper our
favorite memory of dad and Christmas and
we're all gonna go around a room and
read it and we might all weep
we might all bust a gut laughing we
might get really silent but you're not
gonna avoid that weight that that grief
that missing him by ignoring it by by
pretending she didn't exist so get
Upstream ask everybody how we want to
honor this person how we want what we're
going to do and then everybody
participate in it and my promise to you
is you'll feel it you'll feel it but it
will also add a sense of connectivity to
the entire Gathering
awesome all right I don't want to spend
the holidays with my family how do I
tell them without feeling guilty and
then how do I tell my kids
um you probably can't your first time
around do it without feeling guilty
um maybe your second third or fourth
time and Dave Ramsey my buddy likes to
say uh
parents are often travel agents for
guilt trips right so you might say it
and they're like oh I'm gonna make you
feel guilty I'm just gonna beat you
that's just part of of putting at
boundaries is often often is feeling
guilty so get over that part
um and what was the second part of that
so how do you tell your family and then
how do you tell your kids that we're not
going to be seeing you know we told our
family this year was
um I'm coming off a wild travel season
the we are still adjusting to having a
middle schooler and now a first grader
and the new year like heading into the
new year is going to be wild and I've
got a book deadline which makes me holy
unfun to be around and so this
particular Christmas we're not going to
be traveling we're going to stay at home
and we're not going to
um we're not going to have people
staying at our house this year and so I
was just pretty direct but really the
problem the issues if you will they're
all me Centric I'm not going to be a
good Host this year because I've got so
much going on and I want to be a good
Steward of my time and my family and my
rest and that means that the best way I
can love you is by telling you this
isn't a great year and by the way all my
family went oh thank God that'd be so
great to have a year off and so
everybody was glad that I put the
boundary out there
why are family and holiday traditions
important for kids
oh that's such a great question we live
in a culture that has pulled the string
on every tradition
we have this idea that if it's not
Innovative and new it's somehow A Relic
in its trash and we are paying the price
culturally for unwinding all of our
cultural narratives that bind us
together there are some that need to go
some filled with hate and evil those
gotta go but filling everything out is
no bueno because it it leaves you
anchorless with your family with your
community with your traditions and so
giving kids anchor points giving them
memory points if you will core memories
right from the movie Inside Out giving
them those moments every year is Rando
as it is I make sure that one of my kids
I pick them up and we put the star on
top of the tree it's a tradition my mom
and my son watch some movie I forgot
what it is they watch a movie every year
they don't even like the movie anymore
but my son's like it's tradition it's
what we do and it just becomes this
Anchor Point and it becomes a story he's
going to tell at her funeral right the
star thing is going to be a core memory
that my kids remember dad trying to pick
up his humongous 13 year old son and
wheeled him over not knocked the whole
tree over those make important memories
and so give your kids the gift of
tradition give your kids the gift of
recurring memories and recurring actions
that they can anchor to as they move on
through their life
last one and this is kind of connected
to that one what your favorite Christmas
tradition from your childhood
and I just
um all my family very similar to an
earlier question we all lived in the
same city and we all lived in Houston
except for my Aunt Jane and and Uncle
Tom they would come in but we all lived
in the same city but Houston's so big
it's an hour apart and so we never saw
each other and so every Christmas Eve we
got together and all hung out for a few
hours a few awkward fun good hours I
loved it that was my favorite and even
into college and into
um when I was married for the first
decade or so we never missed it we
always went back
um and then I talked about this on a
previous show but the punk rock show
third foot fall every Christmas we went
um me and one or two of my buddies and
it turned into my wife came with me but
that was just a fun Gathering of people
many people who that was their Christmas
celebration and it was fun to get there
and just cut loose and sing some songs
and be a little Rowdy be a little crass
and
go home and plan for the new year
that's it awesome
I wish all these were this this is not
easy but
this simple yeah you really nailed this
one I feel like my mom could have sent
most of these in like
maybe she did ah she probably did she
doesn't listen to this show so that's
all good none of my family does all
right that's fantastic all right hey
does the lightning round that was a
lightning round